[موسيقى]
يمكنهم استخدام التنفس كطريقة إدخال أخرى
لتجربة الواقع الافتراضي
ومن ثم يمكنهم التفاعل بشكل طبيعي مع
البيئة
[موسيقى]
يمكنهم تفجير شموع أعياد الميلاد
يمكنهم تفجير البالونات ، وبالتالي يؤدي ذلك إلى تحسين
تجربة الواقع الافتراضي
[الموسيقى]
إذا كان المستخدمون  المشي
في مشهد حيث يوجد دخان
أو حرارة
ثم يصبح التنفس أصعب كما
تتوقع لذلك نتلاعب
بالمقاومة أكثر قليلاً حتى
يشعروا بتأثير على
الصورة الرمزية الافتراضية والتي من ناحية أخرى
تزيد من التجسيد حتى يشعروا بالمزيد
مرتبطًا بهذه الشخصية الافتراضية
[الموسيقى] ،
نحن جيدون في معالجة الرؤية ، فنحن
جيدون في معالجة الصوت والسمع ، لكن
ما ينقصنا لتحسين التجربة
التي ليس من السهل إدراكها هو
ردود الفعل اللمسية ، فكل ما تلمسه في
الواقع الافتراضي لا يكون كذلك
ليس لديك كائن حقيقي
حقيقي خلفه ، لذا يبدو الأمر كما لو كنت
تلمس الهواء الذي تتفاعل مع الهواء
بشكل أساسي وكلما زادت المدخلات الحسية
التي تقدمها  بالنسبة
للمستخدمين ، كلما كانت التجربة أفضل ،
هناك الكثير من إمكانات
الواقع الافتراضي في محاكاة التدريب لأنهم
يصبحون أكثر غامرة ، يمكنك
تجربة الأشياء في بيئة آمنة
في محاكاة التدريب
وأيضًا ارتكاب الأخطاء والتعلم من
تلك الأخطاء يمكن أن يكون هناك حرائق
تدركها في الواقع الافتراضي لكنها
لا تشكل خطرًا على نفسك حقًا
وبالطبع هناك تطبيقات في
العلاج النفسي
والعلاج بشكل عام حيث يمكنك
إنشاء سيناريوهات غامرة أكثر
قد تكون أكثر إمتاعًا للمستخدمين بحيث
يلتزمون بأنظمة التدريب الخاصة بهم